This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. I want you to imagine a world where you can just invent a musical instrument. I don't mean when you were a kid and you put some rubber bands on a tissue box. I mean you come up with a new instrument almost from scratch and then watch as that instrument gets taken up and played in nearly every marching band, jazz band and high school music classroom across the country. There actually was a time where this kind of thing happened. That's reporter Jay Coburn. In the 19th century, Western Europe saw an explosion of instrument innovation,
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯。我想让你想象这样一个世界：你可以随心所欲地发明一种乐器。我不是指你小时候把几根橡皮筋套在纸巾盒上的那种。我是指你几乎从零开始构思出一种新乐器，然后看着这种乐器被全国几乎每一个行进乐队、爵士乐队和高中音乐教室所采纳并演奏。曾几何时，这种事情确实发生过。那是记者杰·科伯恩。在 19世纪，西欧迎来了乐器创新的大爆发，
where the entire landscape of instrumentation was shifting, and where there was money to be made if your improvements caught on with the public. This is when many of the instruments we know today reached their modern forms. Trumpets had been around since Roman times, but in the 19th century, they took on the valved form we know today, and flutes went from being conical wooden instruments, to metal cylinders. But one of the greatest innovations to come out of this time
当时整个乐器界格局在不断变化，只要你的改进能得到公众的认可，就能赚到大钱。正是在这个时期，我们今天所熟知的许多乐器定型成了现代的模样。小号自罗马时期就已存在，但在 19世纪，它们演变成了我们今天所熟知的带活塞的样式，长笛也从锥形的木制乐器变成了金属圆筒。但那个时代最伟大的创新之一
was the saxophone. The saxophone wasn't an improvement on a previous instrument. It was a brand-new invention, a hybrid of brass and woodwind that not only managed to secure a spot in the musical canon, but also went on to change American music forever. Its design came from the mind of a brash young entrepreneur. His name, perhaps unsurprisingly, was sax.
就是萨克斯管。萨克斯管并不是对以往乐器的改良。它是一项全新的发明，是铜管与木管的结合体，不仅在音乐正宗曲目中争得了一席之地，而且还永远地改变了美国音乐。它的设计出自一位年轻气盛的企业家之头脑。他的名字，也许并不令人意外，就叫萨克斯。
Adolf Sachs was born in Dinole, Belgium, in 1814. His full name was actually Antoine Joseph Sax, but at the time Adolf wasn't, you know, taken. So he went by that instead. It's difficult not to remember him as this romanticized figure, the rags to riches to rags, the fiery temper. This is Dr. Stephen Cottrell, Emeritus Professor of Music at City St. George's University of London.
阿道夫·萨克斯于 1814年出生在比利时迪南。他的全名其实是安托瓦内·约瑟夫·萨克斯，但当时“阿道夫”这个名字还没怎么被人占用，所以他就直接用这个名字了。人们很难不把他当作这样一个浪漫化的人物：经历过从赤贫到暴富再到赤贫，脾气火爆。这是伦敦大学城市圣乔治分校的名誉音乐教授斯蒂芬·科特尔博士。
The brilliant innovator yet saddled with personal demons and professional challenges throughout his life. Dr. Cottrell is the author of a book called The Saxophone, but that book might never have been written because Sacks nearly died before he invented anything, like many, many times. Adolf Sacks was the eldest of 11 children, only four of whom made it to age 30, so the odds were stacked against young Adolf from the start. and I'm going to need a deep breath before I list the ways he apparently nearly died as a kid. He fell three flights of stairs and cracked his head on a stone floor. He drank a mixture of vitriol, probably what we would call sulfuric acid today and water, mistaking it for milk. He was burned in a gunpowder explosion and then again when a frying pan was knocked over.
他是一位才华横溢的创新者，但在其一生中却背负着个人心魔和职业挑战。科特尔博士是《萨克斯管》一书的作者，但这本书可能永远都不会问世，因为萨克斯在发明任何东西之前差一点就死掉了，而且是很多很多次。阿道夫·萨克斯是 11个孩子中的老大，其中只有 4人活到了 30岁，所以从小对小阿道夫来说，命运多舛。在我列举他小时候显然差点送命的种种方式之前，我需要先深吸一口气。他从三层楼的楼梯上摔下来，脑袋在一楼的石地板上摔裂了。他误把稀硫酸（大概就是我们今天所说的硫酸）和水的混合物当成牛奶喝了下去。他在火药爆炸中被烧伤，后来平底锅被打翻时又再次被烧伤。
A stone fell off a roof and left a lifelong scar on his head and he once fell asleep in a room full of freshly varnished furniture, but was luckily found before he succumbed to the fumes. I think what we're getting here is a picture of somebody who is energetic, getting into scrapes, whether it's falling downstairs, whether it's going to sleep in a room where varnish is drying, whether it's having his head cracked open. Some of these stories might be apocryphal,
一块石头从屋顶掉下来，在他头上留下了终生难忘的伤痕，有一次他睡在摆满新漆家具的房间里，幸运的是在被毒气熏死之前被人发现了。我认为我们在这里看到的是一个精力充沛的人的形象：他总是磕磕绊绊，无论是从楼梯上摔下来、在油漆正干的房间里睡着，还是脑袋被砸裂。其中有些故事可能是虚构的，
but this long list of mishaps is probably why his mother once said that, quote, he's a child condemned to misfortune. He won't live. Thanks, Mom. She was right about the first part, but not about the second, because, against all odds, Adolf did survive his tragicomic childhood. And as a young adult, he joined his father in the family business, making musical instruments. Adolf's father, Charles Joseph Sachs, had gotten into instrument making because he was a musician himself.
但这一长串的倒霉事，大概就是为什么他的母亲曾说过，引述：“他是一个命中注定多灾多难的孩子。他活不长的。”谢谢你，妈妈。她前半句说对了，但后半句错了，因为历经艰难险阻，阿道夫确实挺过了他那喜剧悲剧交织的童年。在青年时期，他加入了父亲的家族企业，从事乐器制造。阿道夫的父亲查尔斯·约瑟夫·萨克斯之所以涉足乐器制造，是因为他本人就是个音乐家。
His professional training had been as a carpenter, but when he joined a woodwind band in Dinant, he didn't have an instrument. so he taught himself to make one. That must have gone pretty well because soon he moved to Brussels and set up an instrument shop. That's where young Adolf Sachs learned his craft. I think we have to remember
他受过木匠的专业培训，但当他加入迪南的一个木管乐队时，他没有乐器，于是便自学做了一把。那一定进展得相当顺利，因为不久后他就搬到布鲁塞尔开了一家乐器店。年轻的阿道夫·萨克斯就是在那里学会了他的手艺。我想我们必须记住
we're now talking early 19th century. Musical instrument making in Europe at this time was not done in big factories. There was no industrialisation involved. It was small, artisanal, individual craftsmen. It's much more a craft-oriented tradition. Young Adolf clearly felt the pull of opportunity. As a teen, he was enrolled in the Royal School of Music in Brussels.
我们现在谈论的是 19世纪初。当时欧洲的乐器制造并非在大型工厂里进行。其中不涉及工业化。它是小型的、手工的、由个体工匠完成的。它更像是一个以手艺为导向的传统。年轻的阿道夫显然感受到了机遇的召唤。青少年时期，他就读于布鲁塞尔皇家音乐学院。
He was an impressive musician, a virtuoso on the flute and clarinet. When he was about 20, one composer even dedicated a clarinet piece to Adolf Sax. There was a promising career as a musician waiting for him, but he was lured back to the family instrument workshop. While working alongside his dad, Adolf started experimenting with the instrument he knew best, the clarinet. Specifically, the bass clarinet. The bass clarinet was kind of a quirky novelty at the time.
他是一位令人印象深刻的音乐家，也是长笛和单簧管的演奏大师。大约 20岁时，甚至有一位作曲家专门为阿道夫·萨克斯创作了一首单簧管曲。一条大有可为的音乐家生涯正等待着他，但他又被吸引回了家族的乐器作坊。在与父亲一起工作的同时，阿道夫开始对最熟悉的乐器——单簧管进行试验。具体来说，是低音单簧管。低音单簧管在当时算是一种古怪的新奇玩意儿。
It was difficult to play and sounded kind of nasal, and it was so long that it was difficult to get your fingers in the right place. It looked a bit like a folded bassoon. So Adolf Sax experimented with new keywork, the metal parts that you press to close the holes. He also used the science of acoustics to make the placement of those holes more precise. People would put these boreholes, in more or less wherever they felt it looked about right.
它很难演奏，声音听起来有点像鼻音，而且太长了，手指很难按到正确的位置。它看起来有点像折叠的大管。于是阿道夫·萨克斯尝试了新的按键系统——即按下以关闭音孔的金属部件。他还运用声学科学使这些音孔的位置更加精准。人们以前制作这些钻孔时，基本上是觉得哪里看起来差不多合适就开在哪里。
He came up with the measurements. He decided to make this a much more scientific operation than previously in determining where the holes actually needed to be cut. This improvement meant that each instrument sounded more in tune. And when played together, the bass clarinet sounded more harmonious. And so, in 1835, in his early 20s, Adolf Sachs took his bass clarinet to an instrument show. And 19th century Belgian instrument aficionados loved it.
他想出了测量标准。在确定实际需要切割音孔的位置时，他决定让这项工作比以往更加科学。这一改进意味着每种乐器的音准都更好。当一起演奏时，低音单簧管听起来更加和谐。因此，在 1835年，二十出头的阿道夫·萨克斯带着他的低音单簧管参加了一个乐器展。19世纪的比利时乐器爱好者们对此爱不释手。
In fact, the bass clarinets used in orchestras today still owe their design to Adolf Sax, a wooden tube covered in keys that curves into a metal bell shape at the bottom end. The top end crooks into a mouthpiece with a wooden reed to blow on. In other words, the bass clarinet looks a lot like the saxophone eventually would. With his redesign of the bass clarinet, the name Saxes was beginning to be known in musical circles. But if he really wanted to make the big francs, he had to move to Paris. Brussels were very small at the time, and Paris was one of the major musical centres
事实上，如今管弦乐队中使用的低音单簧管仍然归功于阿道夫·萨克斯的设计：一根覆盖着按键的木管，底部弯曲成金属喇叭口状。顶部则弯曲成带有木质簧片的吹口供吹奏。换句话说，低音单簧管看起来非常像后来的萨克斯管。通过对低音单簧管的重新设计，“萨克斯”这个名字开始在音乐界崭露头角。但如果他真的想赚大钱，他就必须搬到巴黎。当时布鲁塞尔非常小，而巴黎则是欧洲主要的音乐中心之一。
in Europe. And Paris was particularly the centre of brass wind manufacturer. You had to be seen to be producing your new brass and wind instruments if you were going to be successful. In 1843, Adolf Sachs set up a workshop there and got to experimenting. He came up with new families of horns, the sax horns, which were valve brass instruments that looked a bit like upright trumpets, and the saxotrumbas, which were valved brass instruments that looked a bit like upright trumpets. There are videos of people playing these on the internet. This is the sax horn. And this is the saxo tromba. And perhaps it's worth noting here that Adolf Sachs didn't really invent these instruments,
巴黎尤其是铜管乐器制造的中心。如果你想取得成功，你就必须让人看到你正在生产新的铜管和管乐器。1843年，阿道夫·萨克斯在那里建立了一个车间并开始进行试验。他发明了新的号角系列：萨克斯号（sax horns，这是一种活塞铜管乐器，看起来有点像立式小号）和萨克斯特龙巴号（saxotrumbas，也是带活塞的铜管乐器，看起来有点像立式小号）。互联网上有人们演奏这些乐器的视频。这是萨克斯号。这就是萨克斯特龙巴号。也许这里值得一提的是，阿道夫·萨克斯并没有真正发明这些乐器，
so much as improve on things that already existed. And then added sacks to the name. If you asked Adolf, though, he'd probably tell you this was a mere technicality. Don't be such a sax down air. He'd say he was here to disrupt the industry. Move fast and break things. Sax style. Although Adolf was turning out a variety of instruments,
与其说是发明，不如说是对现有事物的改进。然后把“萨克斯”这个名字加了进去。不过，如果你去问阿道夫，他可能会告诉你这只是个技术细节。别这么像个萨克斯扫兴鬼。他会说他是来颠覆这个行业的。快速行动，打破常规。萨克斯风格。尽管阿道夫生产了各种各样的乐器，
None of them had been a big enough hit to make him properly rich. He was one instrument maker among many in Paris, all competing for the attention of orchestras and private buyers. So he came up with a plan to secure his own niche in a competitive market. He went after a client so huge, so wealthy that their business could set him up for life. Because since time immemorial, there's been one tried and true way for an entrepreneur to make a ton of money. Adolf Sachs wanted to land a military contract. If you could get a contract with the French military to supply brass instruments or brass wind instruments, then that was going to be the backbone of your business. You were going to sell far more instruments to the French military than you ever were going to the orchestras in Paris.
但没有哪一种火到能让他真正发财的地步。他是巴黎众多乐器制造商中的一员，所有人都在争夺管弦乐队和私人买家的注意力。因此，他在竞争激烈的市场中想出了一个确保自己一席之地的计划。他瞄准了一位如此庞大、如此富有的客户，以至于他们的生意能让他受用终生。因为自古以来，企业家赚大钱都有一个屡试不爽的方法。阿道夫·萨克斯想要拿下军方合同。如果你能与法国军方签订合同，为他们供应铜管乐器或铜管风鸣乐器，那将成为你业务的顶梁柱。你向法国军方卖出的乐器数量，远超你在巴黎的管弦乐队身上能卖出的数量。
If cannons and cavalry were how a country demonstrated military prowess, then music was how it showed its cultural might. And France was lagging behind. Austria and Prussia's military bands were leading the way with fancy new valve technology in their brass instruments, which made for loud, impressive displays. France's military band, on the other hand, was still dominated by woodwind instruments, which are tuneful and elegant, but not loud enough to fill a parade ground. In 1845, the French Ministry of War established a commission to investigate improvements to military bands, and Sachs decided that he was going to hit it big by designing the purpose.
如果说大炮和骑兵是一个国家展示军事实力的方式，那么音乐就是它展现文化力量的方式。而法国当时却落后了。奥地利和普鲁士的军乐队在铜管乐器中率先采用了新颖华丽的活塞技术，从而呈现出响亮、震撼的展示效果。相比之下，法国军乐队仍然由木管乐器主导，虽然它们音色优美、典雅，但音量不足以填满阅兵场。1845年，法国战争部成立了一个委员会来调查如何改进军乐队，萨克斯决定通过设计专门的产品来一鸣惊人。
perfect instrument to lift French military bands out of the toilettes. Adolf thought he could have the best of both brass and woodwinds, with a little tinkering. His starting point was this other instrument that was common in bands at the time, called the Offerclide. It's a little bit difficult to describe. If you turned a trumpet on its end with the bell pointing up to the sky and then made it about 30 times bigger, you've got the general shape of an Offerck. Clyde. The Offerclide had this going for it. It was loud, but other than that, it was pretty much a dud. It's a big honking instrument that was difficult to play in tune. This is a recording of an Offer Clyde I found online.
旨在将法国军乐队从颓势中拯救出来的完美乐器。阿道夫认为，通过一点小小的改进，他就能兼具铜管和木管乐器的优点。他的出发点是当时乐队中常见的另一种乐器，叫做奥菲克莱号（ophicleide）。这有点难以描述。如果你把一个小号竖起来，让喇叭口指向天空，然后把它放大约 30倍，你就能大致想象出奥菲克莱号的形状。奥菲克莱号有这样一个优点：它声音很大，但除此之外，它基本上是个失败品。它是一个声音巨大、刺耳且很难按准音高演奏的乐器。这是我在网上找到的奥菲克莱号的录音。
The composer Hector Berlioz said, the quality of these low sounds is rude. It is as if a bull escape from its stall had come to play off its vagaries in the middle of a drawing room. The Offerclade was usually part of the low bass end of the orchestra, where the tuba sits today. And so Sacks saw this area of the bands and the orchestras as needing attention, and he therefore looked at the offerclade, and he experimented with the Offerclade. Adolf Sax borrowed from his earlier project, the bass clarinet, and created a sort of hybrid brass and reed instrument. He quite literally took the brass mouthpiece that was on the Offer Clyde and replaced it with a bass clarinet mouthpiece.
作曲家埃克托·柏辽兹曾说过：“这些低音的音质很粗糙。就好像一头从牛棚里逃出来的公牛，跑到客厅正中央去撒野一样。”奥菲克莱号通常属于管弦乐队的低音部分，也就是今天大号所坐的位置。因此，萨克斯认为乐队和管弦乐队的这个区域需要关注，于是他将目光投向了奥菲克莱号，并对奥菲克莱号进行了试验。阿道夫·萨克斯借鉴了他先前的项目——低音单簧管，创造了一种类似铜管与簧片的混合乐器。他字面意义上取下了奥菲克莱号上的铜制吹口，换上了一个低音单簧管吹口。
That's what we believe he did in the late 1830s, and the reed mouthpiece would make a smoother, softer sound. It would make a richer harmonic spectrum. Adolf also placed the boreholes scientifically, the way he had with the bass clarinet. Crucially, this wasn't just one instrument. It was a whole family. Adolf Sax was looking to improve the entire ensemble,
这就是我们认为他在 19世纪 30年代末所做的事情，而簧片吹口会发出更平稳、更柔和的声音。它会产生更丰富的谐波频谱。阿道夫还像处理低音单簧管那样，以科学的方式安置了音孔。至关重要的是，这不单单是一种乐器。而是一个完整的家族。阿道夫·萨克斯旨在改进整个乐队，
and so he created families of similar instruments at different pitches. He'd already done this with the saxhorns and saxotrombas a few years before. The idea was to create a chorus of instruments working together, a little like a choir of human voices, with altos, tenors, sopranos, and bass all working together in harmony. And just like his saxhorns and saxotrombas, he named them after himself, the saxophones. Adolf Saxe patented his family of saxophones in 1846.
因此他创造了音高不同、却彼此相似的乐器家族。几年前他已经在萨克斯号和萨克斯特龙巴号上这样做了。这个想法是创造出一组合奏的乐器，有点像人声合唱团，中音、次中音、女高音和低音全部和谐地协同工作。就像他的萨克斯号和萨克斯特龙巴号一样，他以自己的名字为它们命名——萨克斯管（saxophones）。阿道夫·萨克斯于 1846年为他的萨克斯管家族申请了专利。
There are eight figures on that patent, ranged by size and pitch. Some of them are straight. Some are more like an offaclide. But right at the center of that lineup was an instrument with a bell-shaped horn, a reed mouthpiece, and an iconic S-shaped. Adolf had created a brand-new kind of instrument, one that was light and sturdy. The S-shaped in particular was easy to hold while marching. It was loud enough to carry over a parade ground but with the rich harmonics and refined tone of a clarinet.
该专利图上有八个图形，按大小和音高排列。有些是直的。有些更像奥菲克莱号。但在这个阵容的正中央，是一种带有喇叭状号筒、簧片吹口以及标志性 S形的乐器。阿道夫创造了一种崭新的乐器，轻巧而坚固。特别是那个 S形，在行进时很容易拿握。它的音量足够大，足以盖过阅兵场，同时又具有长笛那般丰富的谐波和精致的音色。
This was the perfect instrument for a military band and it sounded like this. This is the sound of a saxophone made. by Adolf Sachs himself in the 1860s. This antique is being played by Dr. Paul Cohen. When I was reading about the development of the saxophone, pretty much every article was either written by or had contributions from Paul.
这是军乐队的完美乐器，听起来是这样的。这是由阿道夫·萨克斯本人于 19世纪 60年代制作的萨克斯管的声音。这件古董正在由保罗·科恩博士演奏。当我阅读有关萨克斯管发展的资料时，几乎每一篇文章要么是由保罗撰写的，要么有他提供的贡献。
After I called him up, he invited me to visit his saxophone museum in New Jersey. When saxophone has come here, it's like a saxophone painting zoo, because they're allowed to play all these instruments if they bring their mouthpieces. How many saxophones do you have? I stopped counting a while ago, but it's around 250.
在我打电话给他之后，他邀请我参观他在新泽西州的萨克斯管博物馆。当萨克斯管演奏家来到这里时，就像是来到了一个萨克斯管的动物园，因为只要他们带上自己的吹口，就可以演奏所有这些乐器。你有多少支萨克斯管？我前一阵子就不数了，但大概有 250支左右。
Some people say that it's the largest private collection in the world. The Adolf Sachs original is a beautiful instrument. The brass has barely dulled with age. It carries Adolf Saxes' maker's mark engraved next to some ornate cursive script, detailing the address of his workshop in Paris. How does it feel? as a player compared to your modern performance saxophone?
有人说这是世界上最大规模的私人收藏。阿道夫·萨克斯的原作是一件精美的乐器。铜质历经岁月却几乎没有黯淡。它刻有阿道夫·萨克斯的制造商标记，旁边还伴有一些华丽的花体字，详细说明了他在巴黎的车间地址。感觉如何？作为一名演奏者，与你现代演出用的萨克斯管相比？
It's so light and the sound is so transparent. I feel like I'm playing on a cloud. Oh. And I feel that if I play too hard, I'm going to fall through the cloud. That is a lovely metaphor. Sacks had created and patented a whole line of saxophones and sax horns. But that didn't mean he'd sealed the deal for the French military contract. He still needed to present his inventions to the military
它是如此轻巧，声音又是如此透明。我觉得自己就像是在云端演奏。哦。而且我觉得如果我吹得太猛，就会从云端掉下去。这是一个美妙的比喻。萨克斯创造并为整条萨克斯管和萨克斯号产品线申请了专利。但这并不意味着他已经稳操胜券，拿下了法国军方的合同。他仍然需要向军方展示他的发明，
and convince them that these instruments were the key to bringing their band to the next level. Military bands, like the orchestra, can be stuffy, conservative places. You can imagine how they might bristle at a brash young Belgian who slapped his name on a trumpet and called it a sax horn, especially when he starts saying that the military should abandon their oboes and bassoons for all these sax instruments that he just made up. But like any good entrepreneur, Adolf Sachs did a lot of networking in Paris. and he made friends with some very influential composers and writers who really did believe in the superiority of his instruments.
并说服他们这些乐器是让他们的乐队迈上新台阶的关键。军乐队和管弦乐队一样，可能是沉闷、保守的地方。你可以想象他们会对一个狂妄自大的年轻比利时人感到多么反感，这个人在一个小号上贴上自己的名字并称之为萨克斯号，尤其是当他开始说军方应该放弃双簧管和大管，改用他刚刚凭空捏造的所有这些萨克斯乐器时。但像任何优秀的企业家一样，阿道夫·萨克斯在巴黎进行了广泛的社交，并与一些非常有影响力的作曲家和作家交了朋友，他们确实坚信他的乐器具有优越性。
They wrote about Adolf's creations in the musical press, helping him make the case for his vision of a new type of military band. So there was this ongoing debate in the press about what kind of instruments should be in the French military. Ultimately, the commission decided to let the public settle the matter in the only way a musical debate can be settled. A battle of the band.
他们在音乐媒体上撰文报道阿道夫的发明，帮助他为自己对新型军乐队的构想造势。因此，媒体上一直在争论法国军方到底应该使用哪种乐器。最终，委员会决定让公众以音乐辩论唯一能够解决问题的方式来平息这场争议。一场乐队大战。
The French Ministry of War set up a competition to find out whether Saxes' instruments could actually outmatch the instrumentation of a conventional military band. On one side, the sax band, full of sax horns and saxophones, led by Adolf Saxes. His supporters were known as, no surprises here, Saxons. On the other side, a traditional military band, which at the time was Woodwind Heavy, with two oboes, two bassoons, and 13 clarinets. Adolf Sax did away with those oboes and bassoons, and he kept just seven clarinets. In their place, he had 18 sax horns and two saxophones, as well as the more modern trumpets and trombones.
法国战争部举办了一场比赛，旨在弄清楚萨克斯的乐器是否真的能胜过传统军乐队的乐器配置。一边是萨克斯乐队，充满了萨克斯号和萨克斯管，由阿道夫·萨克斯率领。不出所料，他的支持者被称为“萨克斯派”。另一边是传统军乐队，当时的传统乐队以木管乐器为主，包括两把双簧管、两支大管和 13支单簧管。阿道夫·萨克斯取消了那些双簧管和大管，只保留了 7支单簧管。取而代之的是，他配备了 18把萨克斯号和 2支萨克斯管，以及更现代的小号和长号。
This was a big deal. The press was full of rumours about nefarious forces trying to interfere. Now, there are stories that people try to sabotage Saxes' bands. They bought off some of his instrumentalists. They tried to find ways in which the saxis. phones couldn't be played, etc, etc. This kind of thing seemed to happen to Sacks all the time. Throughout his career, you can find wild tales of shadowy enemies
这是一件大事。媒体充斥着关于邪恶势力试图干预的传闻。现在有流言称，有人试图破坏萨克斯的乐队。他们买通了她的一些乐器演奏家。他们试图寻找萨克斯管无法演奏的种种方式，等等。这种事似乎一直发生在萨克斯身上。在整个职业生涯中，你可以发现许多关于隐秘敌人及其企图阻挠他的疯狂传说。有一个故事说，有人在萨克斯的床上安放了一名炸弹。我找到了另一个故事：萨克斯的一名顶级员工被暗杀，刺客错把他当成了老板，一刀刺穿了他的心脏。显然，这些故事可能是真的，其中许多源自耸人听闻的报纸报道或传记，而最初的爆料者正是萨克斯本人或他的至亲。但很显然，他树敌众多。而在乐队大战的那天，萨克斯的七名乐手真的没有出现。他们
and their plans to thwart him. There's one story of a bomb being planted in Sacks' bed. I found another story of one of Sacks' top employees being murdered, stabbed through the heart by an assassin who mistook him for his boss. Apparently, these stories are possibly true, and lots of them originate in sensational newspaper reports or biographies where the original source was Sax himself or his close family. But it's clear that he had made a lot of enemies. And on the day of the Battle of the Bands, seven of Saxes' musicians really didn't show up. They were
显然是被收买而没有露面。但这并没有阻止萨克斯，据说他自己也亲自演奏了其中的一些乐器。1845年 4月 22日，两个乐队、两套不同的乐器以及一架观众聚集在巴黎的长条公共公园——战神广场。今天，这个公园是埃菲尔铁塔的所在地，但在当时，它的核心是军事学校（École Militaire）。媒体炒作引起了公众的兴趣，因此乐队面临着大批观众。观众席中坐着军事委员会的成员。记者、艺术家和高级军官。他们到场是为了评判声音的质量以及它在户外的传播效果。
apparently, apparently bribed to stay out of the way. But that didn't stop Sax, who played some of the instruments himself, apparently. On April 22nd, 1845, two bands, two different sets of instruments, and one audience showed up at the Cham de Mar, a long public park in Paris. Today, the park is home to the Eiffel Tower, but back then, its focal point was the École Militaire, the military school. The press had drummed up public interest, so the bands were facing a large crowd. Among the audience were members of the Military Commission. Journalists, artists, and senior officers. They were there to judge the quality of the sound and how well it carried outdoors.
两个乐队一个接一个地演奏了相同的曲目。以传统木管为主的乐队率先登场。接下来轮到萨克斯乐队那激昂的号角声。萨克斯的乐器会更加同质化。它们合奏起来声音会更好听，部分原因是他制造了其中大部分甚至全部乐器。因此铜管乐器都是按照他的规格制造的。他加入了萨克斯管，这会为乐队增加音量。很明显，音量在这里是一个重要的问题。
The two bands played the same pieces of music, one after the other. The traditional woodwind-centric band went first. Then it was the turn of the rousing horns of the sax band. Saxes instruments would have been more homogenous. They would have sounded better together, in part because he was making most or all of them. And so the brass instruments were all made to his specifications. He added the saxophones in, which would have given more volume to the band. So clearly volume is an important issue here.
这些是声音更大的乐器，由于萨克斯的科学方法，它们的和声可能更加紧密，由军乐队在户外演奏。由于他的萨克斯号，萨克斯乐队拥有更强的低音表现力。经过四个小时的演出，观众为两个乐队欢呼，但对阿道夫·萨克斯的萨克斯乐队的欢呼声更大，大到足以让他被宣布为这场对决的赢家。这个认可的印章对法国军方来说已经足够了。阿道夫·萨克斯赢得了那份极其诱人的军事合同。
These were louder instruments, probably in closer harmony because of Sax's scientific approach, played outdoors by military bands. And the sax band had much more bass presence, thanks to his sax horns. After four hours of performance, the audience cheered for both bands, but the cheers for Adolf Sax's sax band were louder, loud enough for him to be declared the winner of the battle. That seal of approval was enough for the French military. Adolf Sax won that sweet, sweet military contract.
我这里有一段从报纸上翻译过来的非常地道的法式引语。斯特拉迪瓦里小提琴与乡村小提琴相比。一杯醇厚的波尔多葡萄酒旁边是一种在塞兰制造的掺假饮料。那是巴黎的一个郊区。这就是旧音乐与萨克斯先生提议的音乐之间存在的差距。他赢得了合同，为法国军方提供他们更合心意的乐队乐器。
I've got a properly French quote translated from a newspaper here. A Stradivarius violin compared with a violin from the village. A glass of generous Bordeaux next to an adulterated beverage made in serrain. That's a suburb of Paris. That is the difference which exists between the old music and that proposed by Monsieur Sacks. He won the contract to supply the French military with instrumentation for their bands
因此在一段时间里，萨克斯的生意蒸蒸日上。萨克斯的胜利意味着他获得了大量的资金流和稳定的客户。标准的军乐队现在必须包含他的发明：不再有双簧管和大管，现在有了萨克斯号和萨克斯管。他甚至对其他铜管乐器进行了一些技术改进，并出售了他自己版本的铜管乐器。
that was more along the lines he wanted. So for a while then, Saxes' business is booming. Sax's victory meant that he had a huge influx of cash and a steady customer. A standard military band was now required to include his inventions. no more oboes and bassoons, now there were sax horns and saxophones. He even made some technical improvements to the other brass instruments and sold his own versions of those as well.
军旅生活对乐器来说很严苛，需要经常更换。这一切最终为萨克斯带来了庞大的生意。但尽管取得了成功，阿道夫的傲慢和他的敌人们最终还是追上了他。他陷入了昂贵的专利官司中。萨克斯管的专利确实保住了，但当法国在普法战争中失利时，军方缩减了乐队规模。萨克斯背上了无力偿还的贷款，并破产了三次。他失去了工厂，但或许对他而言更心碎的是，他失去了音乐。
Military life was hard on instruments and they needed to be replaced often. All this ended up to big business for sax. But despite his success, Adolf's hubris and his enemies eventually caught up to him. He got tied up in expensive lawsuits over the patents for his instruments. The saxophone patents did hold up, but when France lost the Franco-Prussian war, the military downsized its bands. Sax took on loans he couldn't afford and went bankrupt three times. He lost his factory, but perhaps more heartbreaking to him, he lost his music.
阿道夫·萨克斯收藏的 400多件乐器被没收并拍卖以偿还债务。他会收集那些乐器是因为它们真正代表了他想了解的关于乐器的知识，我认为它们对他来说一定意义重大。因此，尽管它们在金钱上的价值相对较小，但在情感上，这会是一种伤害。因为他花了一生时间建立起那个收藏，小心翼翼地保存着它们，看到它们全被这样卖给别人，受到的伤害可能不亚于发生在他身上的任何其他事情。最后一次破产是在 1877年。他度过了生命的最后 17年，勉强糊口，
Adolf Sax's collection of over 400 musical instruments was taken from him and sold to pay off his debts. He would have been collecting those instruments because they really represented what he wanted to know about musical instruments, I think they would have really meant something to him. And so, although there was relatively little monetary value in them, emotionally, that would have hurt. Because he'd spent a lifetime building up that collection, keeping them carefully, and to see them all sold off to other people like that, would have probably hurt as much as anything else that happened. That final bankruptcy was in 1877. He spent the last 17 years of his life scraping by,
向亲友乞讨金钱。1894年 2月 7日，安托瓦内·Joseph·阿道夫·萨克斯在巴黎因肺炎在绝对贫困中去世。经过阿道夫·萨克斯一生辛勤的工作，他的乐器已不再是一个商业上的成功之作。但他仍在历史上赢得了一席之地。在他的出生地迪南，有他的雕像。如果没有接下来在大洋彼岸发生的事情，那些雕像可能就不会立在那里了。那是休息之后的内容。就在法国军方削减资助、欧洲萨克斯管销量下滑之际，
begging friends and family for money. Antoine Joseph Adolf Sachs died of pneumonia in absolute poverty in Paris on February 7, 1894. After a lifetime of work by Adolf Sachs, his instrument was no longer a commercial success. But he still earned a permanent place in history. There are statues of him in Dinon, where he was born. Those statues probably wouldn't be there if it weren't for what happened next and ocean away. That's after the break. Even as the French military was pulling back funding and saxophone sales in Europe were falling off,
这种乐器正在美国获得越来越多的关注。然而，萨克斯管在美国的地位并不局限于军方。它被作为一种廉价、有趣且相对容易演奏的乐器进行营销，人们对它喜爱有加。事实上，在 20世纪初，美国经历了后来被称为“萨克斯狂热”的时期。美国萨克斯管制造商大批量生产了数十种新奇乐器。其中一种像滑音哨一样滑动。另一种非常小，以至于演奏起来显得荒诞可笑。保罗·科恩在新泽西州的萨克斯管博物馆里收藏了不少这类乐器。
the instrument was gaining traction in the United States. The saxophone's place in the U.S., however, was not just in the military. It was marketed as a cheap, fun instrument that was relatively easy to play, and people loved it. In fact, in the early 20th century, the U.S. experienced what became known as a saxophone craze. American saxophone manufacturers churned out dozens of novelty instruments. One of them glides like a slide whistle. Another is so small, it looks absurd to play. Paul Cohen has quite a few of them at his saxophone museum in New Jersey.
我录下了保罗演奏一堆新奇萨克斯管的声音。它们听起来棒极了。我向你们保证，我们稍后会播放它们的录音。甚至还有一把会吓到我的猫。很快，这些萨克斯管就被用于马戏团、杂耍表演以及人们的家中。它被宣传为一个绝佳的社交工具。吹奏萨克斯管，让自己更受欢迎。这会不会就像，你知道的，你去朋友家里做客，
I recorded Paul playing a bunch of novelty saxophones. They sound amazing. I promise you that we'll play them later. There's even one that scares my cat. Pretty soon, these saxophones were being played in circuses, in vaudeville acts, and in people's homes. It was marketed as a great social tool. Play the saxophone and be more popular. Would it be like, you know, you go around your friend's house
他们家里很可能会有一支萨克斯管？他们更有可能会有两支。家庭音乐制作是一件大事。我们在目录和文章中看到许多图片，展示了家人围坐在钢琴旁，萨克斯演奏者则在一旁看着肩膀，照着钢琴谱演奏，参与到音乐的欢乐中。
and it would be quite likely they'd have a saxophone there? More than likely they'd have two. Home music making was a big deal. And we have many pictures in catalogs and articles that show the family surrounding the piano and the saxophone player, looking over the shoulder, playing off the piano part, participating in the musical merriment.
萨克斯狂热持续从 1915年一直到大萧条爆发前后。人们口袋里的钱变少了，对古怪萨克斯管的需求也随之减少。但萨克斯管并没有消失，狂热时期的所有那些乐器依然在四处流传。它们被拾起并用于开创后来成为美国标志性音乐流派的先河。到了 20世纪 20年代末，大乐队形式的爵士乐开始成为热门音乐和音乐合奏形式。大萧条来了，但我们大家仍然在喝酒派对，对吧？30年代到来了。现在乐队的工作是让舞者留在舞池里。
The saxophone craze lasted from 1915 to around the time the Depression hit. With less money in people's pockets, there was less demand for wacky saxophones. But the saxophones didn't disappear, and all those instruments from the sax craze were still floating around. And they got picked up and used to pioneer what would become America's defining musical genre. When we got to the late 1920s, jazz in a big band form was starting to become the, happening music and music ensemble. Depression's here, but we're all still drinking and partying, right? 30s come along. Now the band's job is to keep the dancers on the dance floor.
这是雷姬莎·本杰明（Lakeisha Benjamin）。她曾与王子（Prince）、史蒂维·旺德（Stevie Wonder）和艾莉西亚·凯斯（Alicia Keys）一起演奏萨克斯管，并获得过六项格莱美奖提名。但是，就像，她曾与王子一起演奏过萨克斯管，我觉得光是这一点就足以作为一个开场白了。她说，20世纪 30年代的爵士乐全在于让人们动起来，当你的工作是让派对继续进行时。而他们为此呼叫的乐器就是萨克斯管。当时甚至还有萨克斯对决。人们会去观看贝西伯爵（Count Basie）对阵艾灵顿公爵（Duke Ellington）的演出。
This is Lakeisha Benjamin. She's played saxophone with Prince, with Stevie Wonder and Alicia Keys, and she's been nominated for six Grammys. But like, she's played saxophone with Prince, and I feel like that alone is enough of an intro. She says that 1930s jazz was all about getting people moving. when it's your job to keep the party going. And the instrument that they called on for that was a saxon. They were even sax battles. People would go and just see Calbasie Van versus Duke Lane's event.
他们会彻底试图在音乐上击败对方。他们的萨克斯管演奏非常狂野。我就算唱出来，虽然听起来会很糟糕。那会是真实的。随着爵士乐的演变，萨克斯管不仅成为了号角组的一部分。它成为了独奏者的乐器，掌控着舞台，迫使你将注意力集中在演奏者身上。所以我不知道这是不是因为所有的男人都在打仗，还是在其他什么地方，但小型乐队出现了，我想猜猜谁是
And they would just completely try to murder each other. Their saxophone playing was real raunchy. I'll just sing it even though it's going to sound terrible. It'd be real. As jazz evolved, the saxophone. phone wasn't just a part of the horn section. It became a soloist's instrument, commanding the stage and forcing you to pay attention to the player. So I'm not sure if that's because all the men are in the war, or wherever they are, but the small group comes and I guess who's the founder
那场运动的创始人？这有争议。我们都说查理·帕克（Charlie Parker）、迪齐·吉莱斯皮（Dizzy Gillespie）和塞隆尼斯·蒙克（Thelonious Monk）是三巨头。他们发明了一种名为比波普（Bebop）的音乐风格。所以我们从大乐队过渡到了比波普。那是查理·帕克在演奏《科科》（Coco）。这确实是我们对萨克斯管的看法：真正充满智性、快节奏的音符（哒-哒-哒-哒-巴-哒-哒-哒-哒-巴），他们就像是炫技大师。你可以说从那一刻起，再也没有人伴着爵士乐跳舞了。爵士乐演奏家使用萨克斯管的方式展示了阿道夫·萨克斯旨在在其乐器中完善的灵活性。当传统的萨克斯演奏家使用宏大、粗犷的音色时，一些爵士乐手则倾向于萨克斯管那流畅、细腻的表现力，
that? It's debatable. We all say Charlie Parker, Disney Gillespie, and Thelonious Monk were the three. And they invent this style of music called Bebop. So we go from Big Band to Bebop. That's Charlie Parker, playing Coco. And this is really what we think of the saxophone as, really intellectual music, fast-nosed, da-da-da-da-ba-da-da-da-da-ba, and they're like virturosals. And you can say from that moment on, no one ever danced to jazz again. The way jazz instrumentalists used the saxophone showcased the flexibility, Adolf Sax, had aimed to perfect in his instrument. While traditional saxophonists use the big brash tones, some jazz players leaned into the saxophone's ability to be smooth and nuanced,
几乎是在模仿人类的声音。我想我是一个如此热爱爵士放克的萨克斯演奏家，对我来说，那样做会束缚我自己。所以，一个很好的例子就是古典萨克斯管。我的声音听起来是这样的。古典萨克斯听起来是这样的。嘿，你好吗？大家最近怎么样？我演奏古典萨克斯管。
almost mimicking the human voice. I guess I'm such a jazz funk saxophone player that, to me, I would be inhibiting myself. So, like, good example of that is classical saxophone. Here's this how my voice sounds. This is how it sounds classical. Hey, how are you? How's everybody doing? I play a classical saxophone.
但不对，这才是我的真实——停，停，停。你看，所以。就像，我感到，我只是感到被压抑，因为我就像，为什么当我说话是这种语气时，我却要那样演奏？为什么你们要让我这么做？求求你们。求求你们，我想演奏爵士乐。到了这个时候，萨克斯管已经从它在欧洲的根源走过了漫长的道路。它不再是那个试图在法国军方崭露头角的狂妄年轻暴发户。在一个世纪的时间里，这种乐器已经融入了美国生活的方方面面，随同音乐会乐队到处巡演，并穿梭于全国各地的起居室中。
But no, this is my real stop, stop, stop. You see so. Like, I felt, I just felt oppressed because I'm just like, why can I play like this when this is how I talk? Why do you want me to do this? Please. Please, I want to play jazz. By this point, the saxophone had come a long way from its roots in Europe. It was no longer the brash, young upstart trying to make it big in the French military. Over the course of a century, the instrument had woven itself into the fabric of life in the U.S., traveling with concert bands and hanging out in living rooms across the country.
它成了一种标志性的美国乐器。而现在，随着爵士乐的兴起，它成了一种黑人美国人的乐器。它变得更具政治色彩，因为它是美籍非洲人创立的。因此，如果我们有一群人创立了一种音乐，而这种音乐开始时他们正遭受压迫，它就已经成了革命的音乐。萨克斯管的新联想并非没有遭到阻力。一些主要是白人的音乐家认为，萨克斯管不应该被爵士乐玷污。
It was an iconic American instrument. And now, with jazz, it was a black Americans instrument. It gets more political because it was founded by African Americans. So if we ever got a group of people that are founding a music that starts off with them oppressed, it's already the music of revolution. The saxophone's new associations did not come without pushback. Some, mostly white musicians, felt that the saxophone, shouldn't be debased by jazz.
他们认为这是一种适合正经人的正经乐器。我有这本杂志专栏，是几位萨克斯管纯粹主义者于 1917年撰写的。让我读一读其中的一部分。愿上帝拯救我们，免受目前大行其道、被称为“爵士化（jassing）”的可怕尖叫之苦。那些听到这些爵士乐手演奏、却从未听过萨克斯管的听众，很可能会对这种饱受议论的乐器产生非常错误的看法。说真的，“爵士乐手”应该受到与患有口蹄疫的人相同的隔离限制。
They thought it was a proper instrument, for proper people. I've got this magazine column here written by a couple of saxophone purists in 1917. Let me just read a bit. God savers from the hideous cat-calling that is so much in vogue at present termed jassing. The listener who hears some of these jazz players and has never before heard a saxophone is liable to form some very erroneous opinions of the much-talked-of instrument. Really, the jasser should be subject to the same quarantine restrictions as if he had the foot and mouth disease.
在 20世纪的前半叶，爵士乐以及由此延伸出的萨克斯管，代表着禁忌。它们是罪恶的代名词。当禁酒令实施时，你要去爵士乐场所买酒。如果你想整晚喝酒、狂欢和乱搞。那就是你要去的地方。而为此伴奏的音乐就是布鲁斯和爵士乐。黑手党就是从那里起家的。所以它与某种，而且长期以来一直获得资助。爵士乐是由做坏事的人资助的。甚至在我自己的家里，我奶奶也不想让我玩
In the first half of the 20th century, jazz, and by extension, the saxophone, represented the forbidden. They were synonymous with sin. When prohibition is going on, you go to the jazz place to get the liquor. If you're trying to drink and party and fornicate, all night. That's where you go. And the music that's playing for that is the blues and jazz. That's where the mafia is with. So it's associated with a, and it's funded for a long time. Jazz is funded by people that are doing wrong. Even in my own household, my grandma didn't want me to play
萨克斯管。她告诉我：“如果你要在这里演奏那个，你得在这个萨克斯管上学几首教堂圣歌。”所以我当时一边试图练习我的艾灵顿公爵，一边还要演奏《圣哉，圣哉，圣哉》。所以我认为如果你来自那个时代，它的任何声音或任何回忆，你都会把它与“我女儿要下地狱了”联系起来。这种作为黑人乐器、与烟雾缭绕的俱乐部和性爱联系在一起的名声，正是这种名声跟随萨克斯管回到了它的欧洲发源地。这种联系如此强烈，以至于当纳粹在 20世纪 30年代掌权时，萨克斯管惹上了麻烦。
the saxophone. She told me, if you're going to play that in here, you've been to learn some church songs on this saxophone. So I'm in there trying to practice my Duke Ellington and also playing holy, holy, holy. So I think if you're from that generation, any sound of it or any recollection of it, you just associate with my daughter's going to hell. This reputation for being a black instrument, an instrument associated with smoky clubs and sex, it's that reputation that followed the saxophone back to its birthplace in Europe. This association was strong enough that the saxophone ran afoul when the Nazis came to power in the 1930s.
爵士乐被认为是黑人音乐。这是达里厄斯·琼斯（Darius Jones）。他是一位作曲家、萨克斯演奏家兼卫斯理大学音乐系助理教授。纳粹可不会，你知道的，他们想禁绝一切。他们并不真正关乎人类体验的丰富性。我觉得萨克斯管，它确实关乎这一点。它确实关乎这种，你知道的，全方位的自我表达。纳粹禁止了他们所谓的“颓废音乐”（entartete music）。
Jazz music was considered Negro music. This is Darius Jones. He's a composer, a saxophonist, and assistant professor of music at Wesleyan University. Nazis don't, you know, they want to ban everything. They're not really about the fullness of the human experience. And I feel like the saxophone, it really was about that. It was really about this sort of like, you know, full sense of expression. The Nazis banned what they called entartete music, degenerate music.
其中包括任何节奏过激、带有犹太式阴郁歌词的东西（我在这里引用的是纳粹的话）。他们甚至办了一个展览，展示所有据称在道德上糟糕透顶的艺术风格。显然，这个展览比展示优秀德国艺术的那个展览要受欢迎得多。有一个海报来自那个颓废艺术展，上面展示了一个黑人男子的种族主义漫画形象，他手里拿着萨克斯管，翻领上别着大卫之星。他吹着萨克斯管，上面印着代表“颓废音乐”的德文字样。苏联也将萨克斯管演奏家送往古拉格劳改营，理由是他们过于资产阶级、过于西方化。萨克斯管曾被梵蒂冈以及世界各地的教堂拒之门外，包括
That included anything with excesses. in tempo, Jewishly gloomy lyrics, I am quoting the Nazis there. They even had an exhibition showcasing all the styles of art that were supposedly morally terrible. It was, apparently, much more popular than the one showcasing fine German art. There's a poster from that degenerate exhibition showing a racist character of a black man holding the saxophone with a star of David pinned to his lapel. He's playing a saxophone with the German words for degenerate music printed over him. The Soviet Union also sent saxophonists to the gulag for being too bourgeois, too western. The saxophone was excluded from the Vatican and then by churches the world over, including
在美国也是如此。可能很难想象，在 20世纪末的一段时间里，萨克斯管曾是法西斯政权的眼中钉。话又说回来，也许并非如此。在 19世纪和 20世纪期间，这种乐器已经经历了一些戏剧性的形态转变。它曾是一个晦涩的赚钱阴谋、一个失宠的军用乐器、一个新奇玩意儿，以及黑人美国音乐的强大象征。那么，成为几个国家和天主教公教会的头号公敌又有什么奇怪的呢？但曾经是禁忌的事物最终往往会成为主流，萨克斯管也不例外。它没有沦为反叛的象征，而是开始向各种流派辐射。在 80年代，尤其是因为我是纽约人，我们开始引入嘻哈音乐。
in the U.S. It might be hard to imagine that for a while in the late 20th century, the saxophone was the boogeyman of fascist regimes. Then again, maybe it's not. Over the course of the 19th and 20th centuries, the instrument had already done some dramatic shape-shifting. It had been an obscure money-making scheme, a fallen military instrument, a novelty item, and a powerful symbol of black American music. So why not enemy number one of several countries and the Catholic Church? But things that were once taboo often eventually go mainstream, and the saxophone was no exception. Instead of remaining a symbol of rebellion, it began to ripple out into a variety of genres. In the 80s, especially since I'm from New Yorker, we're going to start to introduce hip-hop.
在美国，可能很难想象在20世纪末的一段时间里，萨克斯管曾是法西斯政权的眼中钉。话又说回来，也许这并不难想象。在19和20世纪期间，这种乐器已经经历了几次戏剧性的身份转变。它曾是一个鲜为人知的赚钱工具、一件没落的军用乐器、一件新奇物品，以及美国黑人音乐的强大象征。那么，为什么不能成为几个国家和天主教共同的头号敌人呢？但曾经的禁忌往往最终会走向主流，萨克斯管也不例外。它没有一直作为叛逆的象征，而是开始渗入各种流派。在80年代，尤其是因为我是纽约人，我们将开始引入嘻哈音乐。
So they'll take like an eight-bar Donald Bird song and start their song with that. Bum-Bum-Bum-Bum-Bum-Bum-Bum-Bum-Bum. If Dig of All Planets and other hip-hop artists put saxophone to hip-hop, artists like James Brown brought it into mainstream pop music. The 80s were really peak saxophone. The sax became so pervasive that it kind of jumped the shark into cheesiness. It was like of a time, like, you know, leather pants, like, you know, that image of this ponytail, just like playing the saxies all, like, slicked up and stuff. Think careless whisper.
所以他们会拿唐纳德·伯德的一个八小节音符片段来作为他们歌曲的开头。咚、咚、咚、咚、咚、咚、咚、咚、咚。如果说Dig of All Planets和其他嘻哈艺术家将萨克斯风引入了嘻哈音乐，那么詹姆斯·布朗等艺术家则将其带入了主流流行音乐。80年代可以说是萨克斯风的巅峰时期。萨克斯风变得如此无处不在，以至于它有点走向了陈腐和俗气。它带有那个时代的烙印，比如皮裤，你知道的，那种马尾辫的形象，吹奏着萨克斯风，打扮得很油腻的样子。想想《无心快语》。
In the end, the scorching sax solo faded out of fashion, and the saxophone was so ubiquitous that it became kind of just another instrument. One you might pick up in music class at school. Or a bit of extra flavor added to the standard modern rock or pop lineup. Guitar, drums, bass, keys and... Oh, why not a sax? Still, I'd argue that this image of the saxophone is incomplete. It doesn't do justice to the versatile, flexible instrument
最后，火辣的萨克斯独奏逐渐退出了时尚舞台，萨克斯风变得如此普遍，以至于它在某种程度上变成了又一件普通的乐器。一种你在学校音乐课上可能会拿起来演奏的乐器。或者是在标准的现代摇滚或流行乐队中增添的一点额外风味。吉他、鼓、贝斯、键盘，还有……哦，为什么不加一把萨克斯呢？尽管如此，我认为这种萨克斯风的形象是不完整的。它并没有真正体现出这个多才多艺、灵活多变的乐器应有的价值。
that Adolf Sachs put into the world. When people think of love and they think of an instrument, they usually think of some saxophone player coming out and seducing somebody. When it's time to really shred and rock out, you could really crank that thing up and take it all the way to Metallica Land. So for me, it's just the most versatile way to be all your complete self. The saxophone's brilliance has always been in its versatility. When Adolf Sachs invented the saxophone, he designed it to be a marriage of loud and soft, bold and smooth.
阿道夫·萨克斯将它带到了这个世界上。当人们想到爱情并联想到一种乐器时，他们通常会想到某个萨克斯风手走出来魅惑某人。当需要真正狂欢和摇滚时，你其实可以把音量开到最大，把它一直带到金属乐的国度。所以对我来说，这是展现你完整自我的最具多功能性的方式。萨克斯风的 brilliance 一直在于它的多功能性。当阿道夫·萨克斯发明萨克斯风时，他的设计初衷就是将响亮与柔和、大胆与圆润完美结合。
The saxophone is loud enough to hold its own on any stage, but it's also soft and nuanced enough to rise and fall like the human voice. I feel that I'm playing something that is so connected to me internally and physically that it feels like it's an extension of my inner soul. The sound, on a fundamental level, might be made by air vibrating inside a mathematically appropriate metal tube, but how it makes you feel, that's all about the human who's blowing on that read, pressing those keys and feeling the sax appeal. After the break, Jay is going to play us some of his favorite novelty saxophones from Paul Cohen's Saxophone Museum. So we're back with Jay Coburn. Jay, I hear you have some weird saxophones to play me. I absolutely do. So we mentioned the saxophone craze, and I promised you I'd play you some recordings of the kind of weird and wonderful instruments that Paul Cohen has in his sax museum.
萨克斯风的声音足够响亮，足以在任何舞台上站稳脚跟，但它同时也足够柔和细腻，能够像人声一样起伏跌宕。我觉得我演奏的乐器与我的内心和身体如此紧密相连，以至于它感觉就像是我内在灵魂的延伸。从根本上说，声音可能是由数学上合适的金属管内的空气振动产生的，但它带给你的感受，全在于吹奏那个哨片、按下那些键并感受萨克斯风魅力的那个人。休息过后，杰伊将为我们演奏保罗·科恩萨克斯风博物馆里他最喜欢的一些新奇萨克斯风。我们又和杰伊·科本在一起了。杰伊，我听说你有一些奇怪的萨克斯风要弹给我听。我绝对有。所以我们提到了萨克斯风热潮，我向你保证过，我会为你播放一些保罗·科恩在他的萨克斯博物馆里收藏的那些奇妙乐器的录音。
I'm really excited to hear weird saxes. But first, I want you to paint the scene for me because I'm very curious about Dr. Paul Cohen and his saxophone museum. It sounds like this fascinating place. Totally. So the museum is in Englewood, New Jersey. So pretty easy to get to from New York. It's basically just the lower half of his house. And when you walk in, you're just surrounded by saxophones of all shapes, sizes, materials. And you can actually go there too. If you're a bit of a saxophone geek, just search for Paul Cohen on. You can find his email address. And if you send him a message, he will invite you to view his collection, too. If you can play, bring your own mouthpiece, and he'll let you have a go on all these saxophones. I love that. Saxophone shouldn't be just displayed on a wall. They should be played. They should live the life that they're supposed to have. Yeah. And as well as being a professor, he is a professional musician, too. So he uses some of these instruments himself in his work. Okay, so I'm ready to hear some saxophone, some weird saxophone. So what do you want to play first?
我真的很兴奋能听到奇怪的萨克斯。但首先，我想请你为我描绘一下当时的场景，因为我对保罗·科恩博士和他的萨克斯博物馆非常好奇。听起来这是一个迷人的地方。完全正确。这个博物馆在新泽西州的恩格尔伍德。从纽约过去相当方便。它基本上就是他房子的下半部分。当你走进去时，四周环绕着各种形状、大小、材质的萨克斯风。你实际上也可以去那里。如果你是一个萨克斯风极客，只需在网上搜索保罗·科恩。你可以找到他的电子邮件地址。如果你给他发信息，他也会邀请你参观他的收藏。如果你会演奏，带上你自己的吹嘴，他会让你在所有这些萨克斯风上试吹一下。我太喜欢这样了。萨克斯风不应该只被陈列在墙上。它们应该被演奏。它们应该过上它们本该拥有的生活。是的。而且除了教授身份外，他也是一位专业音乐家。所以他在自己的作品中也使用其中一些乐器。好的，我已经准备好听一些萨克斯风了，一些奇怪的萨克斯风。那么你想先播放哪一个？
Okay, first up is a slide saxophone. So you've heard of a slide guitar, I'm sure, but there is also a slide saxophone. And so instead of having loads of holes and keys all over it, this is just a straight tube. This one's actually made of wood, and there is just one long hole down the side of it. And the player kind of presses down a long strap, like literally just a fabric strap, to make that hole longer or shorter, which means you can do a glistando or a slide. And this is how it sounds. I think it sounds.
好的，首先登场的是滑音萨克斯。所以你一定听说过滑音吉他，但其实也有滑音萨克斯。所以它上面没有密密麻麻的孔和按键，这只是一根直管。这个实际上是用木头做的，沿着它的一侧只有一个长孔。演奏者可以通过压下一条长长的带子，字面意思就是一块织物带子，来让这个孔变长或变短，这意味着你可以做一个滑音（glissando）或滑奏。这就是它的声音。我觉得它的声音听起来...
I think it sounds kind of like a theramine, you know, the weird electric instrument. Totally. Or the fanciest slide whistle you've ever heard. Yeah, it's a really expensive kazoo or something. So what do you have next? So I have the extremes of the saxophone now, the biggest and the smallest. So Adolf Sachs designed a whole family of saxophones at different pitches,
我觉得它听起来有点像特雷门琴，你知道的那个奇怪的电子乐器。完全没错。或者是你听过的最花哨的滑音口哨。是的，它是一个非常昂贵的卡祖笛之类的东西。那么你接下来有什么？接下来我带来了萨克斯风的两个极端，最大和最小的。所以阿道夫·萨克斯设计了一整套不同音高的萨克斯风家族，
but later on, manufacturers really took the saxophone to sort of almost comic sizes, and Paul has collected like all of them. He has this teeny tiny little guy that honestly looks like a toy, but is actually a one-of-a-kind curved sopranino. So that's higher than soprano. know. And these are usually straight, but the one Paul has looks like a really intricate toy saxophone. And here it is. That's delightful. I'm picturing like his big grown man hands on this tiny little thing. Is that
但后来，制造商真的把萨克斯风做成了几乎滑稽的大小，保罗几乎把它们全都收集齐了。他有这个微型的小家伙，老实说它看起来像个玩具，但实际上是一个独一无二的弯曲超高音萨克斯（sopranino）。所以它的音高比高音萨克斯还要高。你知道的。这些通常是直的，但保罗有的这个看起来像一个非常精致的玩具萨克斯。这就是它。这太令人愉快了。我脑海中浮现出他那只成年男人的大手抓着这个小东西的画面。是这样吗
what it looks like? Yeah, that's exactly what it looks like. Like it looks, I mean, this is a respectable instrument and we should give it. The degree of respect that it deserves, you know, I believe that was a solo from a Gershwin piece, actually. Yeah, no, it's beautiful. It sounded so good. It's just delightful. I love it so much. Okay, so at the other end of the spectrum, we have the biggest saxophone. And this is the reason that the study door, you can see behind me, is actually closed right now. I have two cats, and this one freaks them out.
看起来是这样的吗？是的，完全是这样的。看起来，我的意思是，这是一件正经的乐器，我们应该给予它。它应有的尊重，你知道的，我相信那其实是一段格什温作品中的独奏。是的，不，这太美妙了。听起来太棒了。这简直太令人愉快了。我太喜欢了。好的，在光谱的另一端，我们有最大的萨克斯风。这就是为什么我身后的书房门现在其实是关着的。我有两只猫，这个大家伙会吓到它们。
So this is the subcontra bass. Oh, that's awesome out, though. It sounds like an old truck, you know, idling outside your house when it gets to the lowest levels. So that is the subcontra bass. That is the lowest, largest type of saxophone. It goes lower than the lowest end of a piano. And it is huge. Like, this thing is being played on a stand because it's taller than Paul is.
所以这就是次低音萨克斯（subcontrabass）。哦，不过听起来真的很棒。当它达到最低音阶时，听起来就像一辆老旧卡车在你家门外怠速空转。这就是次低音萨克斯。那是最低、最大的萨克斯风类型。它的音高比钢琴的最低端还要低。而且它非常巨大。这个东西必须放在支架上演奏，因为它比保罗还要高。
And it's gorgeous, though. It's this beautiful black with brass keywork. And if you're in the room with it being played, or if you just want to crank your speakers, it kind of shakes your guts around and makes you reconsider what you had for lunch. Yeah, yeah. Like, it's definitely something you feel in your sternum when it plays. Okay, so blow my mind, what's the weirdest saxophone you saw there? Okay, so the weirdest one I found in Paul's saxophone museum was this.
不过它很华丽。这是漂亮的黑色搭配黄铜按键。如果你和它处在同一个房间里听它演奏，或者如果你只是想把音量开到最大，它会震动你的内脏，让你重新考虑你午餐吃的是什么。对，对。就像，当它演奏时，你绝对能在胸骨中感受到它。好吧，让我大开眼界吧，你在那里看到的风最奇怪的萨克斯是什么？好的，我在保罗的萨克斯博物馆里发现的最奇怪的是这个。
Take a look at this picture. Okay, so this is a black and white photo of a man. He's kind of sitting perched on a little seat, and he has a stand where three saxophones are affixed in position, and he seems to be playing them all at once. He is. He's playing them all. He's playing one with each hand, and then there's a middle one that he's also blowing
看看这张照片。好的，这是一张一个男人的黑白照片。他有点局促地坐在一个小座位上，他有一个支架，上面固定着三个萨克斯风，他似乎在同时演奏它们。他确实在演奏。他正在演奏它们全部。他用每只手演奏一个，然后中间还有一个他也在吹奏的萨克斯
that is operated with the foot pedals. you can maybe see on the floor there, and he blows them all at once. He was called Billy True. He was a pipe fitter at a steelworks, but he was also known as the one-man saxophone section. And Paul actually has this triple-saxophone contraption in his museum. And so can Paul play this thing? No. And I do not blame him for not trying. But I do have a recording of Billy True playing it.
这是通过脚踏板来操作的。你也许可以在地板上看到，他同时吹奏着它们。他叫比利·特鲁（Billy True）。他是钢铁厂的管道工，但他也以“一人萨克斯风乐队”而闻名。保罗的博物馆里其实就有这个三管萨克斯风的奇特装置。那么保罗会玩这个东西吗？不会。我不怪他没有尝试。但我确实有比利·特鲁演奏它的录音。
All right, Billy True, playing three saxophones at the same. time. I mean, that one strikes me as more of a ridiculous novelty, you know what than anything. But that's great. That's a wacky sax. I like it. Okay, I've got two more that are wacky, but are not strictly saxophones.
好吧，比利·特鲁，同时演奏三个萨克斯风。我的意思是，比起别的什么，这给我的感觉更像是一个荒谬的新奇玩意儿。但那很棒。那是一个古怪的萨克斯。我喜欢它。好的，我还有两个古怪的乐器，但它们严格来说不是萨克斯风。
They are not in Paul's Saxophone Museum, but they are from the mind. of Adolf Sachs himself, because back when our man Adolf was trying really hard for that military contract, he came up with some truly unhinged ideas. And this one is a real, hear me out, the saxo canon. I mean, so are we talking about just an instrument here, or is this actually, like, a weapon? It's a canon with Sax's name on it. Yeah. Like a giant cannon. He's huge. He's branching out. He's really, he wanted the military contract so much. He was like, look, my tubes don't have to just fire sounds, they can also fire balls of metal. And in this case, it was a 30-foot-wide shell. So in theory, it would generate an explosion big enough to level a city. Wow. I'm kind of glad he
它们不在保罗的萨克斯博物馆里，但它们来自阿道夫·萨克斯本人的大脑，因为当年我们的阿道夫先生为了争取那个军事合同而非常努力时，他想出了一些真正精神错乱的主意。而这个真的是个——听我解释——萨克斯大炮（saxo-cannon）。我的意思是，我们是在讨论一件乐器，还是这实际上就像是一个武器？这是一个印有萨克斯名字的大炮。对。就像一个巨型大炮。他太巨大了。他在扩展业务。他真的，他太想要那个军事合同了。他当时想，看，我的管子不仅可以发射声音，它们还可以发射金属球。而在这个例子中，它是一个30英尺宽的炮弹。所以理论上，它会产生足以夷平一座城市的巨大爆炸。哇。我有点庆幸他
stuck to instruments in the end. Yeah. Okay. So one last absurd sax invention, also huge. This one is a train with an organ on the back. It would have been called the Saxo-tonaire, which I believe translates literally as sacks thunder, or maybe it's thunder sacks. Why would anyone want or need an organ the size of a train? To scare the Prussian army, of course. Oh, right. Yeah, you know, why else would anyone want a massive organ?
最后还是坚持做乐器了。好的。最后一个荒谬的萨克斯发明，同样巨大。这是一个后面带着管风琴的火车。它本来应该被称为“萨克斯雷鸣号”（Saxo-tonaire），我认为字面翻译过来就是萨克斯雷鸣，或者也许是雷鸣萨克斯。为什么会有人想要或者需要一个火车那么大的管风琴？当然是为了吓唬普鲁士军队。哦，对的。是的，你知道的，还有什么别的原因会让人想要一个巨大的管风琴吗？
That Prussian army always causing trouble. The idea was that they'd just blast sound at them, like the Scottish did with their bagpipes and the English. And I can say from experience that one worked. I should say that these two SACs stories, the Saks Turner and the Sacks Canon, bit like lots of Adolf Sacks stories, kind of shrouded in myth and lacking reliable primary sources. But I have spent a lot of time with Adolf over the last few months. And I've got to say, sounds like something he'd do.
那支普鲁士军队总是惹麻烦。这个想法是，他们会直接向他们轰鸣声音，就像苏格兰人对他们的风笛和英国人所做的那样。我可以凭经验说那个确实管用。我应该说，这两个萨克斯的故事，“萨克斯雷鸣号”和“萨克斯大炮”，有点像许多阿道夫·萨克斯的故事一样，笼罩在神话之中，缺乏可靠的第一手资料。但在过去的几个月里，我和阿道夫相处了很长时间。我不得不说，这听起来确实像是他会做的事。
Yeah, yeah, because he just likes to take an invention and, like, make it bigger, more ridiculous. Maybe add some valves and some scientific thinking to it and then just slap his name on the front of it. I mean, that's a definitely, that's an at-all sex move. Well, this was so much fun, Jay. I enjoyed the story so much, and I enjoyed this tour through even weirder saxophones. This is fantastic. Thanks for having me, Roman. It's been a joy.
对，对，因为他就是喜欢拿一个发明，然后把它做得更大、更荒谬。也许在上面加几个阀门和一些科学思维，然后把他的名字拍在正面。我的意思是，这绝对是一个典型的阿道夫·萨克斯风格的举动。嗯，这太有趣了，杰伊。我非常喜欢这个故事，我也很享受这次对更奇怪的萨克斯风的参观。这太棒了。谢谢你邀请我，罗曼。这是一次非常快乐的经历。
99% Invisible was reported this week by J. Coburn and edited by Kelly Cobrae and edited by Kelly Gonzalez, music by Swan Real with Kaylee, Kaylee, Maloy on saxophone. Fact-checking by Graham Hesha. Kathy 2 is our executive producer. Kurt Colestead is our digital director. Delaney Hall is a senior editor. The rest of the team includes Chris Barube, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Lay, Lodgemaidon, Joe Rosenberg, Jacob Medina Gleason, Tallin and Rain Stradley, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of his logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the Series X-M podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north, in the Pandora building. In beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find us in all the usual social media sites as well as our own Discord server.
本周的《99%隐形》由杰伊·科本（J. Coburn）报道，由凯利·科布雷（Kelly Cobrae）和凯利·冈萨雷斯（Kelly Gonzalez）剪辑，音乐由斯旺·雷尔（Swan Real）创作，凯莉·马洛伊（Kaylee Maloy）演奏萨克斯。事实核查由格雷姆·海沙（Graham Hesha）完成。凯西·图（Kathy 2）是我们的执行制片人。库尔特·科尔斯特德（Kurt Colestead）是我们的数字总监。德莱尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）是高级编辑。团队其他成员包括克里斯·巴鲁贝（Chris Barube）、杰森·德莱昂（Jason DeLeon）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、维维安·莱（Vivian Lay）、洛奇·梅多恩（Lodgemaidon）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、雅各布·梅迪纳·格里森（Jacob Medina Gleason）、塔林和雷恩·斯特德利（Rain Stradley），以及我，罗曼·马斯（Roman Mars）。99%的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯（Stefan Lawrence）创作。我们是天狼星XM（Sirius XM）播客家族的一部分，现在总部设在位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的上城区的潘多拉大楼以北六个街区。你可以在所有常规社交媒体网站以及我们自己的Discord服务器上找到我们。
There's a link to that, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. I don't know. I don't know. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在 99PI.org 上可以找到该链接以及 99PI 的每一期往期节目。我不知道。我不知道。这期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。